This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗手交往过时，她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast on The Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast on The Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English|||我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的平台上收听The Look Back at it播客。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻，84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year|||每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何撑过那段日子的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了。
For black people Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
For black people Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.|||对黑人群体而言。在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都算不上安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen. and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen. and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode|||有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须这么做，收听。在AHA radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听learn the hard way。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客，新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新一期节目。
as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to start out by asking you a few questions. Do you ever feel like you need to be perfect, that you are responsible for the emotions of others? You are the organizer of the friendship group, highly self-reliant, an overachiever, constantly anxious about the future, thinking about whether your siblings and your parents are going to be okay, do you feel like you grew up too quickly, almost like you were asleep for a huge chunk of your childhood and just never got to experience it, cannot remember it at all? I would make a good guess that if you answered yes to all of those questions, you are the eldest daughter and you might be experiencing what has been coined as eldest daughter syndrome. That is exactly what we are going to
as we break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to start out by asking you a few questions. Do you ever feel like you need to be perfect, that you are responsible for the emotions of others? You are the organizer of the friendship group, highly self-reliant, an overachiever, constantly anxious about the future, thinking about whether your siblings and your parents are going to be okay, do you feel like you grew up too quickly, almost like you were asleep for a huge chunk of your childhood and just never got to experience it, cannot remember it at all? I would make a good guess that if you answered yes to all of those questions, you are the eldest daughter and you might be experiencing what has been coined as eldest daughter syndrome. That is exactly what we are going to|||我们将深入剖析20多岁时的心理。我想先问大家几个问题。你是否曾觉得自己必须完美，是否觉得其他人情绪的好坏是你的责任？你是朋友圈的组织者、极度自立、追求卓越、对未来感到持续焦虑、总是担心兄弟姐妹和父母是否安好，你是否觉得自己长得太快了，就像在童年的很大一部分时间里都在沉睡，根本没有真正去经历过，甚至完全记不得了？我敢大胆猜测，如果你对所有这些问题都回答“是”，那你就是长女，而且你可能正在经历被称为“长女综合征”的状况。这正是我们今天要|||
be discussing in today's episode. This was so highly requested after the episode we did on the curse of being an overachiever where we spoke about this very briefly. But if you haven't listened to that episode, make sure you add it to your cue because it's kind of like a sister episode in some way. It will answer a lot more questions for you, but today we are specifically just talking about the eldest daughter. So the eldest daughter in a family often faces a very unique set of experiences and I would say responsibilities due to kind of the parallel influence of birth order, age and then gender as well. The pressure and the expectations associated with these characteristics
be discussing in today's episode. This was so highly requested after the episode we did on the curse of being an overachiever where we spoke about this very briefly. But if you haven't listened to that episode, make sure you add it to your cue because it's kind of like a sister episode in some way. It will answer a lot more questions for you, but today we are specifically just talking about the eldest daughter. So the eldest daughter in a family often faces a very unique set of experiences and I would say responsibilities due to kind of the parallel influence of birth order, age and then gender as well. The pressure and the expectations associated with these characteristics|||在今天的节目中要讨论的内容。在我们制作了关于“追求卓越者的诅咒”那一期节目并对此进行了简短讨论后，大家对这个话题的呼声极高。但如果你还没听过那一期节目，请务必把它加入你的播放列表，因为某种程度上它就像是姐妹篇。它会为你解答更多疑问，但今天我们专门只谈长女。因此，家庭中的长女往往会面临一组非常独特的经历，我想说，由于出生顺序、年龄以及性别的共同影响，她们还承担着独特的责任。与这些特征相关的压力和期望|||
cause eldest daughters to develop very specific certain personality traits or even mental health challenges as well because they have been required to grow up a lot quicker, be a role model or even a caregiver to their younger siblings and also live up simultaneously to the very high expectations of their parents. Elder's daughters often fit a certain profile in that way, a certain personality profile. They're often very self-reliant and independent. They find it hard to trust other people with tasks that need to be done because that would require them to give up a
cause eldest daughters to develop very specific certain personality traits or even mental health challenges as well because they have been required to grow up a lot quicker, be a role model or even a caregiver to their younger siblings and also live up simultaneously to the very high expectations of their parents. Elder's daughters often fit a certain profile in that way, a certain personality profile. They're often very self-reliant and independent. They find it hard to trust other people with tasks that need to be done because that would require them to give up a|||会导致长女养成非常特定的一些性格特质，甚至面临心理健康方面的挑战，因为她们从小就被要求更快地成熟，成为弟弟妹妹的榜样甚至是照顾者，同时还要达到父母极高的期望。长女在某种程度上往往符合某种特定的侧写，一种特定的性格侧写。她们通常非常自立且独立。她们发现很难将需要完成的任务交给别人去做，因为这需要她们放弃|||
sense of control. They often feel accountable for the family's happiness, future well-being. They're complimented on being mature for their age. They are labeled as an overachiever or my favorite term, a gifted child. I despise that term from a young age. And there's a lot of pressure, either explicit or implicit, that has put on them to get perfect grades and to really excel at their careers. They have a lot of people-pleasing tendencies. They're afraid to say no, to let people down. And then, of course, we have like the age-old stereotype of eldest daughters being very bossy and domineering, which, if I'm being honest, I tend to agree with as the eldest child.
sense of control. They often feel accountable for the family's happiness, future well-being. They're complimented on being mature for their age. They are labeled as an overachiever or my favorite term, a gifted child. I despise that term from a young age. And there's a lot of pressure, either explicit or implicit, that has put on them to get perfect grades and to really excel at their careers. They have a lot of people-pleasing tendencies. They're afraid to say no, to let people down. And then, of course, we have like the age-old stereotype of eldest daughters being very bossy and domineering, which, if I'm being honest, I tend to agree with as the eldest child.|||对控制感的需求。她们常常觉得有责任维护家庭的幸福和未来的福祉。人们称赞她们少年老成。她们被贴上“优秀生”或者我最讨厌的词——“天才儿童”的标签。我从小就厌恶这个词。她们身上背负着大量的显性或隐性压力，要求她们取得完美的成绩，并在职业生涯中出类拔萃。她们有很强的讨好型人格倾向。她们害怕拒绝，害怕让别人失望。当然，还有关于长女非常专横霸道的陈旧刻板印象，说实话，作为家里的老大，我对此深表赞同。|||
There are thousands, I would say if not millions, and possibly billions, let's stick with millions, millions of eldest daughters out there who can relate to these quote-unquote symptoms and the experiences of elder daughter syndrome. We are seeing viral TikToks of people kind of describing the stress of the excessive emotional and physical labour that we take on. But most importantly, at the core of this experience, the impression that we aren't being cared for the way that we care for others. That is so critical.
There are thousands, I would say if not millions, and possibly billions, let's stick with millions, millions of eldest daughters out there who can relate to these quote-unquote symptoms and the experiences of elder daughter syndrome. We are seeing viral TikToks of people kind of describing the stress of the excessive emotional and physical labour that we take on. But most importantly, at the core of this experience, the impression that we aren't being cared for the way that we care for others. That is so critical.|||有成千上万，可以说如果不是数百万，甚至可能是数十亿（我们还是说数百万吧），数以百万计的长女能够对这些所谓的“症状”以及长女综合征的经历产生共鸣。我们看到TikTok上疯传着各种视频，人们在描述我们所承担的过度情感和体力劳动的压力。但最重要的是，这种体验的核心在于，我们有一种感觉：我们并没有得到像我们照顾别人那样悉心的关照。这一点至关重要。|||
And I think that is such a source of pain for eldest daughters in particular. And when we see that many people, I think, talking about a unique experience of a certain type of person in society, I think it's something that we need to pay attention to and explore, because there is so much surprising psychology that comes with holding this position and this role in the family. And I think a lot of unexpected, sometimes long-term consequences that linger with us into adulthood impacting things like how we view our academics or work or career success or romantic relationships, even what happiness actually looks like for us. So there are theories around birth order, around parentification, early 20s rebellion, gender theory, so much to cover.
And I think that is such a source of pain for eldest daughters in particular. And when we see that many people, I think, talking about a unique experience of a certain type of person in society, I think it's something that we need to pay attention to and explore, because there is so much surprising psychology that comes with holding this position and this role in the family. And I think a lot of unexpected, sometimes long-term consequences that linger with us into adulthood impacting things like how we view our academics or work or career success or romantic relationships, even what happiness actually looks like for us. So there are theories around birth order, around parentification, early 20s rebellion, gender theory, so much to cover.|||我认为这正是长女们痛苦的根源所在。当看到这么多人都在谈论社会中某一类人群的独特经历时，我认为这是我们需要关注和探讨的课题，因为占据家庭中的这个位置和角色，背后蕴含着许多令人惊叹的心理学。而且我认为这会带来许多意想不到的、有时甚至是长期的后果，这些后果会一直延续到我们的成年期，影响我们如何看待学业、工作、职业成功或恋爱关系，甚至影响我们对幸福的定义。因此，这里面涉及出生顺序理论、父母化现象、20岁出头的叛逆、性别理论等诸多内容。|||
and I feel personally very invested in this topic and all the research and the studies and psychology that come along with it because as I said I'm the eldest daughter I'm one of three kids I have two younger sisters with an age gap of about six and eight years and as we have all grown up it's been so interesting to see how our dynamic and personalities have been influenced by like where we were born in like how which which order we were born in you know like the middle child the youngest child the oldest child particularly how much responsibility i feel for my sisters i moved out of home when you know one of them was 10 and one of them was 12 like they were still children and so it's so interesting that in my mind they still are those little kids like running around i feel such a sense of like
and I feel personally very invested in this topic and all the research and the studies and psychology that come along with it because as I said I'm the eldest daughter I'm one of three kids I have two younger sisters with an age gap of about six and eight years and as we have all grown up it's been so interesting to see how our dynamic and personalities have been influenced by like where we were born in like how which which order we were born in you know like the middle child the youngest child the oldest child particularly how much responsibility i feel for my sisters i moved out of home when you know one of them was 10 and one of them was 12 like they were still children and so it's so interesting that in my mind they still are those little kids like running around i feel such a sense of like|||我个人对这个话题以及随之而来的所有研究和心理学倾注了极大的热情，因为正如我所说，我是长女，我是三个孩子中的老大，我有两个妹妹，年龄分别相差大约六岁和八岁。随着我们长大成人，看着我们的互动模式和性格如何受到出生顺序（比如我们出生的先后顺序，中间的孩子、最小的孩子、最年长的孩子）的影响，这真的非常有趣，尤其是我对妹妹们感到的那份责任感。我搬离家的时候，你知道的，一个10岁，另一个12岁，她们当时还是小孩子。所以很有趣的是，在我的脑海里，她们依然是当年那些跑来跑去的孩子，我心中油然而生一种强烈的|||
protectiveness for them but i'm also able to acknowledge the level of the level of of like permissiveness that they now have from my parents how the household rules have really changed and also the additional emotional labor that I feel like I do for the family that quite frankly I'm happy to do but the older I've gotten the more I've started to perhaps recognize that maybe my enjoyment of that has been conditioned rather than like voluntarily chosen as I've explored this further and talk to others it's so fascinating to see how what I thought was unique to how was raised may actually have been a lot more based on the fact that I'm not just the eldest child, but also a girl, well, a woman now, but a girl once. Nearly every single one of my female
protectiveness for them but i'm also able to acknowledge the level of the level of of like permissiveness that they now have from my parents how the household rules have really changed and also the additional emotional labor that I feel like I do for the family that quite frankly I'm happy to do but the older I've gotten the more I've started to perhaps recognize that maybe my enjoyment of that has been conditioned rather than like voluntarily chosen as I've explored this further and talk to others it's so fascinating to see how what I thought was unique to how was raised may actually have been a lot more based on the fact that I'm not just the eldest child, but also a girl, well, a woman now, but a girl once. Nearly every single one of my female|||保护欲，但我也能意识到父母现在对她们的宽容度达到了什么程度，家里的规矩真的发生了多大的变化，以及我还为这个家庭付出了额外的精神劳务——坦白说，我挺乐意去做的，但随着年龄的增长，我越来越开始意识到，也许我对这种付出的享受是被后天塑造的，而不是出于完全自愿的选择。随着我对此的深入探讨并与他人交流，我发现了一个非常迷人的现象：我原本以为是我成长经历中所独有的东西，实际上很大程度上是因为我不仅仅是长女，而且还是个女孩——嗯，现在是个女人了，但曾经是个女孩。几乎我的每一位女性|||
friends are eldest daughters. Maybe because part of our shared experiences has kind of brought us closer or meant that our styles and ways of thinking, our values are so aligned. Because we know what it's like to have people relying on us all the time and we know what it's like to never really feel appreciated to feel like we have to do it all. It's really actually quite fascinating because in an article published in Scientific America, they actually concluded that firstborn children are more likely to actually associate with other firstborn children and like be friends with them. Middleborns, more likely to be friends with people who are middleborn and last bones are also more likely be friends with lastborn. So it's like, it's kind of like we pick our friends based on where we were
friends are eldest daughters. Maybe because part of our shared experiences has kind of brought us closer or meant that our styles and ways of thinking, our values are so aligned. Because we know what it's like to have people relying on us all the time and we know what it's like to never really feel appreciated to feel like we have to do it all. It's really actually quite fascinating because in an article published in Scientific America, they actually concluded that firstborn children are more likely to actually associate with other firstborn children and like be friends with them. Middleborns, more likely to be friends with people who are middleborn and last bones are also more likely be friends with lastborn. So it's like, it's kind of like we pick our friends based on where we were|||朋友都是长女。也许是因为部分共同经历拉近了我们的距离，或者意味着我们的风格、思维方式以及价值观高度一致。因为我们懂那种随时随地被人依赖的感受，也懂那种从未真正被认可、觉得自己必须包揽一切的感觉。这其实相当有趣，因为在《科学美国人》发表的一篇文章中，他们得出的结论是：头胎出生的孩子更有可能与其他头胎孩子交往并成为朋友。中间出生的孩子更倾向于和中间出生的孩子交朋友，老幺也更有可能和老幺交朋友。所以这就像是，我们选择朋友似乎取决于我们在家庭中|||
born in the family and kind of the personality traits that we share. Then I started looking at my past relationships. I saw this pattern of only ever dating people who are either only children or younger sons. That's when it got a little bit weird for me. Because I started thinking, like, am I just replicating the relationship that I had with my family? siblings by choosing people that I can almost mother. Someone pointed out to me that when you've taken on the caregiving, people pleasing role, the independent role, your entire life with your family, you can't just switch it off when it comes to your relationships. You repeat the same role you have been taught to play your entire life just in a slightly different way. And one way
born in the family and kind of the personality traits that we share. Then I started looking at my past relationships. I saw this pattern of only ever dating people who are either only children or younger sons. That's when it got a little bit weird for me. Because I started thinking, like, am I just replicating the relationship that I had with my family? siblings by choosing people that I can almost mother. Someone pointed out to me that when you've taken on the caregiving, people pleasing role, the independent role, your entire life with your family, you can't just switch it off when it comes to your relationships. You repeat the same role you have been taught to play your entire life just in a slightly different way. And one way|||出生的顺序以及我们共同的性格特征。接着，我开始审视自己过去的情感经历。我发现了一种规律：我约会过的人全都是独生子或者是家里的幼子。从那时起，事情对我来说变得有点诡异了。因为我开始思考：我是不是仅仅在通过选择那些几乎需要我当母亲去照顾的人，来复制我和家里兄弟姐妹的关系？有人向我指出，当你一辈子都在家庭中扮演照顾者、讨好者和独立者的角色时，面对亲密关系，你是无法随手把它关掉的。你只是换了一种略微不同的方式，重复着你从小被教导要扮演的那个角色。而其中的一种表现方式|||
that shows up in relationships, particularly romantic relationships, is the concept of the mental load. So the mental load refers to a lot of that invisible labor that we often take on of like organizing and planning, not just our lives, but the lives of our partner, you know, keeping track of where things are in the house, reminding your partner of appointments or plans, you know, to text their mom on their birthday, always planning what you're going to do on the weekend, going on a trip and making sure the flights are booked, the itinerary is finalized, the travel insurance is paid for. That is a lot. That is a little. That is the mental load. And it's more than just emotional and physical labor. It's this unequal
that shows up in relationships, particularly romantic relationships, is the concept of the mental load. So the mental load refers to a lot of that invisible labor that we often take on of like organizing and planning, not just our lives, but the lives of our partner, you know, keeping track of where things are in the house, reminding your partner of appointments or plans, you know, to text their mom on their birthday, always planning what you're going to do on the weekend, going on a trip and making sure the flights are booked, the itinerary is finalized, the travel insurance is paid for. That is a lot. That is a little. That is the mental load. And it's more than just emotional and physical labor. It's this unequal|||在恋爱关系等亲密关系中体现出来的，就是“心理负担”这个概念。心理负担指的是我们经常承担的大量隐形劳动，比如组织和规划——不仅是我们自己的生活，还有伴侣的生活。你知道的，比如记住家里东西放在哪里、提醒伴侣注意预约或计划、记得在他们妈妈生日时发短信、总是提前规划周末的活动、安排旅行时确保机票已订好、行程已敲定、旅游保险已买好。这真的非常繁重。这就是心理负担。这不仅仅是情感和体力劳动，这是一种不平等的|||
reliance on the cognitive resources, particularly of women, particularly of eldest daughters, in a relationship. I always thought that I was just a planner. It turns out maybe not. These are just a few of the ways that I've seen this syndrome kind of manifest in my social relationships. But there are so many other areas where we see consequences and influence on behavior. I mentioned this one before. I think it's one of the biggest ones, but overachieving and perfectionist tendencies. I think eldest daughters are second only to only children in the level of academic pressure that they endure, but also due to the individual attention that they receive from their parents before the arrival of their other siblings. It feels like there is
reliance on the cognitive resources, particularly of women, particularly of eldest daughters, in a relationship. I always thought that I was just a planner. It turns out maybe not. These are just a few of the ways that I've seen this syndrome kind of manifest in my social relationships. But there are so many other areas where we see consequences and influence on behavior. I mentioned this one before. I think it's one of the biggest ones, but overachieving and perfectionist tendencies. I think eldest daughters are second only to only children in the level of academic pressure that they endure, but also due to the individual attention that they receive from their parents before the arrival of their other siblings. It feels like there is|||对认知资源的依赖，这种现象在亲密关系中的女性身上，尤其是长女身上尤为明显。我一直以为自己只是个擅长规划的人。事实证明，也许并非如此。这些只是我看到这种综合征在我的社会关系中表现出来的冰山一角。但在许多其他领域，我们也能看到它对行为产生的后果和影响。我之前提到过这一点。我认为这是最主要的影响之一，那就是追求卓越和完美主义倾向。我认为长女所承受的学业压力仅次于独生子女，同时这也是因为在其他兄弟姐妹出生之前，她们得到了父母极大的专属关注。感觉好像有|||
more of a spotlight on them, that they have an example to set. As we spoke about in our episode on overachievers, when your worth becomes tied to external praise, to accolades, to accomplishment, you begin to lose touch with your inherent worth, but also find it really impossible to slow down or just take a break without feeling guilty. We start to equate rest with laziness, even if your parents aren't saying anything anymore, even if it just becomes self-imposed. You're also more likely to be highly empathetic and sensitive. That's a good one. But mainly the reason for that is because you see your role in the family, in any kind of relationship or group dynamic as keeping people happy. That is your job to be the mediator.
more of a spotlight on them, that they have an example to set. As we spoke about in our episode on overachievers, when your worth becomes tied to external praise, to accolades, to accomplishment, you begin to lose touch with your inherent worth, but also find it really impossible to slow down or just take a break without feeling guilty. We start to equate rest with laziness, even if your parents aren't saying anything anymore, even if it just becomes self-imposed. You're also more likely to be highly empathetic and sensitive. That's a good one. But mainly the reason for that is because you see your role in the family, in any kind of relationship or group dynamic as keeping people happy. That is your job to be the mediator.|||更多的聚光灯打在她们身上，她们需要树立一个榜样。正如我们在关于“追求卓越者”的那期节目中所谈到的，当你的自我价值与外部的赞扬、荣誉和成就绑定在一起时，你便开始与自己内在的价值失去联系，同时你会发现自己根本无法放慢脚步或仅仅休息一下而不感到内疚。我们将休息等同于懒惰，哪怕父母已经不再说什么了，哪怕这完全成了自我施加的压力。你也更有可能具备高度的同理心和敏感度。这倒是个优点。但主要原因在于，你将自己在家庭中、在任何关系或群体互动中的角色视为“让大家开心”。当调解员就是你的工作。|||
So that requires an additional level of hypervigilance towards small emotional cues and reactions of other people. I believe that this also contributes to a sense of protectiveness that we have when it comes to our siblings. I'm not a mother. I have never had a child. But you know that thing that new parents say when they're like, when my child was born, I realized like I could never love anything more like I would die for this child? I kind of get that. I feel that when it comes to my siblings. It's like this fierce sense or acknowledgement that God forbid, you're your parents were to pass away, you would be the caregiver. You are the eldest.
So that requires an additional level of hypervigilance towards small emotional cues and reactions of other people. I believe that this also contributes to a sense of protectiveness that we have when it comes to our siblings. I'm not a mother. I have never had a child. But you know that thing that new parents say when they're like, when my child was born, I realized like I could never love anything more like I would die for this child? I kind of get that. I feel that when it comes to my siblings. It's like this fierce sense or acknowledgement that God forbid, you're your parents were to pass away, you would be the caregiver. You are the eldest.|||因此，这需要对他人微小的情绪线索和反应保持额外的超高度警惕。我相信，这也促成了我们在面对兄弟姐妹时所展现出的那种保护欲。我不是母亲。我从未生过孩子。但你知道新手父母常说的那种话吗？当他们的孩子出生时，他们会意识到：“我从未如此深爱过什么，我可以为了这个孩子去死。”我有点能理解这种感受。当面对我的兄弟姐妹时，我也有同感。就好像有一种强烈的感觉或认知：万一——老天保佑千万别发生——父母去世了，你就是照顾者。你是老大。|||
You have to take care of the family in some way. You have to take care of the younger kids. I think that's maybe one of the upsides of being the eldest daughter, not that like impending sense of doom, but the sense of like protectiveness, but then also independence and leadership that a lot of eldest daughters have. It's what makes them like so great in the workplace
You have to take care of the family in some way. You have to take care of the younger kids. I think that's maybe one of the upsides of being the eldest daughter, not that like impending sense of doom, but the sense of like protectiveness, but then also independence and leadership that a lot of eldest daughters have. It's what makes them like so great in the workplace|||你必须以某种方式照顾这个家庭。你必须照顾年幼的孩子。我想这也许是身为长女的好处之一，倒不是说那种迫在眉睫的厄运感，而是那种保护欲，还有许多长女所具备的独立性和领导力。正是这些特质让她们在职场中|||
and like so great when it comes to, leading a group of people or being a really good friend is that they are a natural born leader. That emotional sensitivity though also has its downsides, especially as we are going into the holiday season as I'm recording this, I think it becomes very apparent where this begins to harm us. All of the family comes together, there's going to be tension or at least chaos, a lot of chores to be done, cooking, cleaning, shopping, hosting. The eldest daughter often steps up during this time and probably experiences the most emotional and mental exhaustion second only to their mothers because that is who they've learned to do this from. That is their female role model.
and like so great when it comes to, leading a group of people or being a really good friend is that they are a natural born leader. That emotional sensitivity though also has its downsides, especially as we are going into the holiday season as I'm recording this, I think it becomes very apparent where this begins to harm us. All of the family comes together, there's going to be tension or at least chaos, a lot of chores to be done, cooking, cleaning, shopping, hosting. The eldest daughter often steps up during this time and probably experiences the most emotional and mental exhaustion second only to their mothers because that is who they've learned to do this from. That is their female role model.|||以及在领导团队或成为极好的朋友时表现得如此出色，因为她们是天生的领导者。然而，这种情感敏感度也有其负面影响，特别是当我们正录制节目迎来假期时，我认为这种特质开始伤害到我们的地方变得显而易见。全家人聚在一起，难免会有紧张气氛，或者至少是一片混乱，有大量的家务要做：做饭、打扫、购物、招待。长女通常会在这个时候挺身而出，所经历的情感和精神疲惫可能仅次于她们的母亲，因为她们就是从母亲那里学会做这些的。那是她们的女性榜样。|||
Obviously that's not true in all cases, but think about who in your family does the most work around the holiday season, not just physical chores, but who carries the mental load? I would bet you it's the women in your family and I would bet you that you are one of those women. One person put this so well, it's like being the eldest daughter is, like having an unpaid internship for the rest of your life. This really points to how the combination of gender and birth order causes us to take on so much more physical, emotional, mental, cognitive labor and from a young age. So the younger that you begin doing that, the younger that you become the eldest sibling, the eldest daughter, the more of a lifelong impact that is going to have on
Obviously that's not true in all cases, but think about who in your family does the most work around the holiday season, not just physical chores, but who carries the mental load? I would bet you it's the women in your family and I would bet you that you are one of those women. One person put this so well, it's like being the eldest daughter is, like having an unpaid internship for the rest of your life. This really points to how the combination of gender and birth order causes us to take on so much more physical, emotional, mental, cognitive labor and from a young age. So the younger that you begin doing that, the younger that you become the eldest sibling, the eldest daughter, the more of a lifelong impact that is going to have on|||当然，并非所有情况都如此，但想想在节日期间，你家里谁干的活最多，不仅是体力家务，谁承担了心理负担？我敢打赌，那是你家里的女性，我更敢打赌，你就是那些女性之一。有人把这一点总结得太精辟了：当长女就像是获得了一份终身无薪实习。这切实指出了性别与出生顺序的结合如何导致我们从很小的时候起，就承担了如此之多的体力、情感、精神和认知劳动。因此，你开始做这件事的年龄越小，你成为大姐、长女的年龄越小，它对你产生的影响就会越深远，伴随|||
you because you have really, I don't know, not been indoctrinated, but you've really taken on this role as part of your identity. It has been part of your reality for a lot longer. So why does this happen? Why, like how do we get here? Why is it that we all share such a similar experience as the eldest daughter? Well, let's break it down. I want to start by firstly discussing the psychology behind birth order. So in the early like 1900s, this Austrian psychiatrist called Alfred Adler, who you might remember from last week's episode, he came up with the idea of styles of life and also the inferiority complex. But he coined birth order theory. And he proposed that the order in which children are born has a really profound impact on the individual personalities.
you because you have really, I don't know, not been indoctrinated, but you've really taken on this role as part of your identity. It has been part of your reality for a lot longer. So why does this happen? Why, like how do we get here? Why is it that we all share such a similar experience as the eldest daughter? Well, let's break it down. I want to start by firstly discussing the psychology behind birth order. So in the early like 1900s, this Austrian psychiatrist called Alfred Adler, who you might remember from last week's episode, he came up with the idea of styles of life and also the inferiority complex. But he coined birth order theory. And he proposed that the order in which children are born has a really profound impact on the individual personalities.|||你的一生，因为你真的——我不知道该怎么说，虽谈不上被洗脑，但你确实把这个角色当成了自我认同的一部分。它作为你现实生活的一部分已经很久很久了。那么，为什么会这样？为什么，我们是如何走到这一步的？为什么作为长女，我们都有着如此相似的经历？好吧，让我们来剖析一下。我想先从探讨出生顺序背后的心理学开始。在20世纪初左右，这位名叫阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒的奥地利精神病学家——大家可能还记得上周节目中提到过他——他提出了生活风格以及自卑情结的概念。但他更是“出生顺序理论”的创立者。他提出，孩子出生的先后顺序对个人性格有着非常深远的影响。|||
So he proposed that firstborns tend to be really neurotic, so like stressful, stressed, more like it, quite dutiful, quite independent, quite conservative. Middle children are competitive, they are rebellious, but they're also people pleases. And the youngest sibling tends to be creative, attention seeking, not very rule following. This has been debated for many, many years, but with a lot of renewed focus in the last decade or two. And when you think about it, obviously where you are born in the family is going to be important, especially since about 80% of us actually have siblings. That is a big part of our childhood and our upbringing. We spend so much time with our brothers and sisters. They share our childhood. Like that's kind of the beautiful part of it. They share our childhood with us. But also they have a very
So he proposed that firstborns tend to be really neurotic, so like stressful, stressed, more like it, quite dutiful, quite independent, quite conservative. Middle children are competitive, they are rebellious, but they're also people pleases. And the youngest sibling tends to be creative, attention seeking, not very rule following. This has been debated for many, many years, but with a lot of renewed focus in the last decade or two. And when you think about it, obviously where you are born in the family is going to be important, especially since about 80% of us actually have siblings. That is a big part of our childhood and our upbringing. We spend so much time with our brothers and sisters. They share our childhood. Like that's kind of the beautiful part of it. They share our childhood with us. But also they have a very|||因此他提出，头胎孩子往往非常神经质，也就是压力山大、更容易感到压力，相当顺从、相当独立、相当保守。中间的孩子好胜、叛逆，但同时也是讨好型人格。最小的兄弟姐妹则往往富有创造力、渴望关注、不太遵守规则。这个理论已经被争论了许许多多年，但在过去的一二十年里，它又重新受到了广泛关注。仔细想想，显而易见，你在家里出生的排行是很重要的，尤其是考虑到我们当中大约80%的人其实都有兄弟姐妹。这是我们童年和成长过程中非常重要的一部分。我们花大量时间与兄弟姐妹相处。他们分享我们的童年。这可以说是其中美妙的部分。他们和我们共同经历童年。但同时，他们与父母也有着非常|||
different relationship to your parents, right? Like each of you, I think, if you have siblings, notices that the level of closeness, the level of like connection, what you, how, what your parents talk to you about, what they trust you with, it's all very different, very different sometimes. So research does suggest some pretty strong kind of shifts in the experiences of firstborns and second borns. So this one researcher from Penn State who was really like the leader in this kind of area of psychology, she puts it really well when she was summarizing her. research. Parents tend to be really focused on getting it right with the first child, leading them to kind of fixate on their firstborn's development growing up. They're really fixated on their health,
different relationship to your parents, right? Like each of you, I think, if you have siblings, notices that the level of closeness, the level of like connection, what you, how, what your parents talk to you about, what they trust you with, it's all very different, very different sometimes. So research does suggest some pretty strong kind of shifts in the experiences of firstborns and second borns. So this one researcher from Penn State who was really like the leader in this kind of area of psychology, she puts it really well when she was summarizing her. research. Parents tend to be really focused on getting it right with the first child, leading them to kind of fixate on their firstborn's development growing up. They're really fixated on their health,|||不同的父母关系，对吧？如果你有兄弟姐妹，我想你们每个人都会注意到，亲密的程度、连结的程度、父母和你谈论的话题、父母托付给你的事情，全都大不相同，有时甚至天差地别。因此，研究确实表明，头胎和二胎的经历存在着相当明显的转变。宾夕法尼亚州立大学的一位研究人员，可以说是这个心理学领域的权威，她在总结自己的研究时做出了非常精彩的阐述。父母往往把全部精力放在如何“正确”抚养第一个孩子上，导致他们过度关注头胎孩子的成长发育。他们死死盯着孩子的健康情况、|||
on their grades, on the friends that they choose, because they're kind of like the first one out the gate, right? They're the first kind of go that they have. With their subsequent children, though, they might be less anxious, they feel less need to micromanage, and that can lead to less tension in like the parent-child dynamic because there's less of a spotlight on the second, third, fourth child. They begin to relax, maybe now because they have like a quote-unquote backup. I know that sounds terrible, but they've kind of learned the ropes a little bit and they've realized that they can be a little bit more hands-off. So the way they treat the second, third, fourth child is different. And in one study published in the journal for family and marriage,
on their grades, on the friends that they choose, because they're kind of like the first one out the gate, right? They're the first kind of go that they have. With their subsequent children, though, they might be less anxious, they feel less need to micromanage, and that can lead to less tension in like the parent-child dynamic because there's less of a spotlight on the second, third, fourth child. They begin to relax, maybe now because they have like a quote-unquote backup. I know that sounds terrible, but they've kind of learned the ropes a little bit and they've realized that they can be a little bit more hands-off. So the way they treat the second, third, fourth child is different. And in one study published in the journal for family and marriage,|||成绩、交的朋友，因为他们就像是第一发出笼的小鸟，对吧？这是他们初为人父母的第一次尝试。然而，对待随后的孩子时，他们的焦虑感可能会降低，觉得没必要事事微操，这反而能减轻亲子关系中的紧张气氛，因为打在第二个、第三个、第四个孩子身上的聚光灯没有那么耀眼了。他们开始放松下来，也许是因为现在有了所谓的“备胎”（我知道这听起来很糟糕），但他们确实摸索到了一些门道，意识到自己可以采取放手不管的态度。因此，他们对待老二、老三、老四的方式是不同的。在发表在《家庭与婚姻杂志》上的一项研究中，|||
research has found that on average, one way that this shows up is that parents experience less conflict with their secondborn than their firstborn. They seem to be less strict with each child. They kind of relax the rules. So whilst the firstborn really had to push up against maybe a strict system, like a certain level of discipline, as the parents have more children, they get a lot more relaxed. They have more kids to focus on. They just don't have the energy to make sure, everyone's following the rules all the time. I think that that is what contributes to the real sense of like, I need to be perfect. I need to set the example, but also I have a sense of responsibility, not just to our siblings, but also to our parents, right? The first child is the
research has found that on average, one way that this shows up is that parents experience less conflict with their secondborn than their firstborn. They seem to be less strict with each child. They kind of relax the rules. So whilst the firstborn really had to push up against maybe a strict system, like a certain level of discipline, as the parents have more children, they get a lot more relaxed. They have more kids to focus on. They just don't have the energy to make sure, everyone's following the rules all the time. I think that that is what contributes to the real sense of like, I need to be perfect. I need to set the example, but also I have a sense of responsibility, not just to our siblings, but also to our parents, right? The first child is the|||研究人员发现，平均而言，这种现象的一种表现是：父母与二胎发生冲突的频率要低于头胎。他们对每个孩子的管教似乎都不那么严格了。他们放宽了规矩。因此，当头胎不得不去对抗那种严厉的体制或某种程度的纪律时，随着父母生下更多的孩子，他们的态度也变得越来越放松。他们有更多的孩子需要关注，实在没有精力去确保每个人无时无刻都在遵守规则。我认为正是这一点，造成了那种真实的想法：“我必须表现完美。我必须树立榜样，同时我不仅对兄弟姐妹负有责任，对父母也负有责任。”老大是唯一一个有机会在完全没有其他孩子干扰的情况下单独了解父母的孩子，对吧？|||
only child who gets to know their parents on a completely solo basis, right? Like, before the other kids come along. So they're like the third member in the relationship for a little bit. And because they're around their parents a lot more for entertainment and comfort, whereas kids born later on can kind of turn to their siblings for that, they really get to know them particularly well. And they're very attuned to their emotions and their feelings and their behavior. In some cases, especially if a couple maybe had a child to try and save their relationship or they've placed a lot of their future in this child or we're seeing some degree of like emotional stability with our parents maybe divorce or financial insecurity we see a secondary process take place here called prerentification
only child who gets to know their parents on a completely solo basis, right? Like, before the other kids come along. So they're like the third member in the relationship for a little bit. And because they're around their parents a lot more for entertainment and comfort, whereas kids born later on can kind of turn to their siblings for that, they really get to know them particularly well. And they're very attuned to their emotions and their feelings and their behavior. In some cases, especially if a couple maybe had a child to try and save their relationship or they've placed a lot of their future in this child or we're seeing some degree of like emotional stability with our parents maybe divorce or financial insecurity we see a secondary process take place here called prerentification|||在其他孩子出生之前。所以在一段时间里，他们就像是这个关系中的第三个成员。而且由于他们更多地围着父母寻求娱乐和慰藉（而后出生的孩子则可以转向兄弟姐妹寻求这些），他们对父母的了解格外深刻。他们对父母的情绪、感受和行为非常敏感。在某些情况下，特别是如果一对夫妇生孩子是为了挽救他们的感情，或者他们将大量未来寄托在这个孩子身上，亦或是我们看到父母的情绪稳定性存在某种问题——比如离婚或财务危机——这里就会发生一个被称为“父母化”的次要过程。|||
prerentification involves kind of a role reversal between parent and child so the child begins to fulfill the emotional needs of the parents the child begins to provide advice and comfort they take on a job to help the family pay the bills, they are assigned more household responsibilities, their achievements are taken as the parent's achievements, whereas the parent gets to be a lot more relaxed, gets to be a lot more like free and emotional and like a little bit wild. That is what parenthification is. And it occurs a lot when there is like some kind of disruption in the family and there is an eldest child who takes on the responsibility. And they may also try and shield younger family members from really hard experiences like arguments or separations.
prerentification involves kind of a role reversal between parent and child so the child begins to fulfill the emotional needs of the parents the child begins to provide advice and comfort they take on a job to help the family pay the bills, they are assigned more household responsibilities, their achievements are taken as the parent's achievements, whereas the parent gets to be a lot more relaxed, gets to be a lot more like free and emotional and like a little bit wild. That is what parenthification is. And it occurs a lot when there is like some kind of disruption in the family and there is an eldest child who takes on the responsibility. And they may also try and shield younger family members from really hard experiences like arguments or separations.|||“父母化”涉及父母与孩子之间的一种角色对调，即孩子开始满足父母的情感需求，孩子开始提供建议和慰藉，他们承担起帮家里付账单的工作，被分派了更多的家务责任，他们的成就被视为父母的成就，而父母则变得更加放松、更加自由、情绪化甚至有点随性。这就是“父母化”。当家庭发生某种变故且由长子或长女承担起责任时，这种情况经常发生。他们可能还会试图保护年幼的家庭成员，使其免受争吵或分离等残酷经历的伤害。|||
And that is kind of why we see that level of protectiveness, that level of responsibility form. Additionally, the eldest child gets all the important information first, right? They often, they are raised by the book, they are taught all the rules, all the chores, the expectations, and therefore they're responsible for teaching the younger children, leading to a sense of physical and emotional accountability and responsibility. they're kind of like the third parent in some ways, which is why they're often asked to serve as babysitters as role models, advice givers for their younger siblings. That's that final element, right?
And that is kind of why we see that level of protectiveness, that level of responsibility form. Additionally, the eldest child gets all the important information first, right? They often, they are raised by the book, they are taught all the rules, all the chores, the expectations, and therefore they're responsible for teaching the younger children, leading to a sense of physical and emotional accountability and responsibility. they're kind of like the third parent in some ways, which is why they're often asked to serve as babysitters as role models, advice givers for their younger siblings. That's that final element, right?|||这也就是为什么我们会看到那种保护欲和责任感的形成。此外，老大最先获得所有重要信息，对吧？他们通常是按照育儿书被养大的，被灌输了所有的规矩、家务劳动和期望，因此他们有责任去教导年幼的弟弟妹妹，从而培养出一种身体和情感上的问责感与责任感。在某种程度上，他们就像是“第三个家长”，这也是为什么他们经常被要求充当弟弟妹妹的保姆、榜样和出谋划策者的原因。这就是最后的那个要素，对吧？|||
Once your eldest child is old enough, you've got like a free babysitter, like an inbuilt free babysitter that you don't have to pay. Someone you can give your duties as a parent to, even if it's just temporary. And that is a kind of emotional and physical labour. that is not expected from the younger siblings. Even if it may seem minor, even if it's not all the time, sometimes the impact is cumulative. We learn from those moments in which we have been asked to take on
Once your eldest child is old enough, you've got like a free babysitter, like an inbuilt free babysitter that you don't have to pay. Someone you can give your duties as a parent to, even if it's just temporary. And that is a kind of emotional and physical labour. that is not expected from the younger siblings. Even if it may seem minor, even if it's not all the time, sometimes the impact is cumulative. We learn from those moments in which we have been asked to take on|||一旦你的大孩子年龄够大了，你就相当于拥有了一个免费保姆，一个内置的、不用花钱的免费保姆。你可以把作为父母的职责托付给这个人，哪怕只是暂时的。这是一种情感和体力上的劳动，而这种要求是不会对年幼的弟弟妹妹提出的。即使这看起来微不足道，即使并非无时无刻都在发生，但这种影响有时是日积月累的。我们从那些被要求承担责任的时刻中汲取经验，|||
kind of the duties of a third parent and they help create our personality. And whilst your siblings get to be kids, you kind of had to play caregiver in those moments. So interestingly, one study suggested that when firstborns, particularly elder's daughters, leave the home, their relationship with their family actually tends to improve.
kind of the duties of a third parent and they help create our personality. And whilst your siblings get to be kids, you kind of had to play caregiver in those moments. So interestingly, one study suggested that when firstborns, particularly elder's daughters, leave the home, their relationship with their family actually tends to improve.|||扮演着第三位家长的职责，而这些时刻塑造了我们的性格。当你的兄弟姐妹可以尽情做孩子时，你在那些时刻却不得不扮演照顾者的角色。有趣的是，一项研究表明，当头胎（尤其是长女）离开家时，他们与家庭的关系实际上往往会有所改善。|||
And the conflict commonly increases between parents and their younger children because they have now taken the spot of the eldest child in the house. The spotlight is now put on them. We also might kind of see a delayed teenage rebellion for the eldest child when they move out, when they get their own place, when they go off to university, where after years of kind of needing to be perfect, to be the role model, to do well in school, to perform a lot of emotional labour, they suddenly have all this freedom.
And the conflict commonly increases between parents and their younger children because they have now taken the spot of the eldest child in the house. The spotlight is now put on them. We also might kind of see a delayed teenage rebellion for the eldest child when they move out, when they get their own place, when they go off to university, where after years of kind of needing to be perfect, to be the role model, to do well in school, to perform a lot of emotional labour, they suddenly have all this freedom.|||而父母与年幼孩子之间的冲突通常会加剧，因为年幼的孩子现在填补了家中长子的位置。聚光灯现在打在了他们身上。我们还可能会看到老大在搬出去住、拥有自己的住所、上大学时出现“延迟的青春期叛逆”——在经历了多年需要表现完美、做榜样、在学校成绩优异、承担大量情感劳动的日子后，他们突然获得了所有的自由。|||
They suddenly get to live for themselves or be their own person, and they go a little bit wild in response. Now, some of these conclusions apply to all oldest children, not just daughters, but when you combine birth order with gender, that's when we really start to see this particular pattern and syndrome emerge. So we are going to discuss the influence of gender, of culture, and also the ways that we can take care of ourselves as the eldest daughter after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
They suddenly get to live for themselves or be their own person, and they go a little bit wild in response. Now, some of these conclusions apply to all oldest children, not just daughters, but when you combine birth order with gender, that's when we really start to see this particular pattern and syndrome emerge. So we are going to discuss the influence of gender, of culture, and also the ways that we can take care of ourselves as the eldest daughter after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||他们突然可以为自己而活，做回真实的自我，作为回应，他们会变得有点疯狂。现在，其中一些结论适用于所有头胎孩子，不仅仅是女儿，但当你把出生顺序与性别结合起来时，我们才真正开始看到这种特殊的模式和综合征浮现。因此，在短暂的广告之后，我们将探讨性别、文化的影响，以及作为长女我们该如何照顾好自己。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。|||
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier,
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier,|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、保持体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，透过那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾深信种子油生来就具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的|||
person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,
person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,|||人。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，在IHeart Radio App、Apple podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？还是坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人那次？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在Look Back at a播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何撑过那段日子的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因，但只是让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了，|||
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||所以我开始发现这里面有一条贯穿的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为没有比这更对黑人群体至关重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。|||
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.|||在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。|||
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,|||生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得活在世上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、|||
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctor. This particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctor. This particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.|||压力和目标展开真实的对话，尽在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》。打开免费的IHeartRadio App。搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她言词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你篡改了。这个特定的测试做了两次，太多了。我篡改过测试一次。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款究竟被用在了什么地方。|||
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.|||阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。又有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。|||
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Gender introduces its own influences to family dynamics. We like know, we know this. Women are raised differently to boys.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Gender introduces its own influences to family dynamics. We like know, we know this. Women are raised differently to boys.|||随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。性别对家庭动力学带来了自身的影响。我们心知肚明，我们对此了如指掌。女性和男孩的养育方式不同。|||
They have treated differently by society. Even when our parents try their hardest to make it equal, sometimes it's unconscious because it's based on how they were raised and they may not even realize or recognize how that might be continuing to promote a very traditional, outdated role of what women are meant to do. When we think about the traditional role of women and girls, their place has been for many, many centuries in the home, performing a lot of that invisible domestic labour.
They have treated differently by society. Even when our parents try their hardest to make it equal, sometimes it's unconscious because it's based on how they were raised and they may not even realize or recognize how that might be continuing to promote a very traditional, outdated role of what women are meant to do. When we think about the traditional role of women and girls, their place has been for many, many centuries in the home, performing a lot of that invisible domestic labour.|||社会对待她们的方式也不同。即使我们的父母竭尽全力做到平等，有时这也是无意识的，因为这是基于他们自己的成长方式，他们甚至可能没有意识到或认清这可能在继续助长一种关于女性应当做什么的非常传统、过时的角色定位。当我们想到妇女和女孩的传统角色时，很多很多个世纪以来，她们的归宿一直都是家庭，承担着大量隐形的家务劳动。|||
There is a higher expectation on girls from a young age to be responsible and sensible. Even in like the school system as well, women are also normally what we would call the family's keeper, meaning they perform a lot of that invisible labour of making sure everybody's happy, that conflicts are resolved and everybody feels paid attention to. They keep the peace as mediators and they also don't call a lot of attention to themselves. And although many cultures are now turning away from that conventional and unequal treatment of girls and boys, particularly when it comes to domestic duties, it takes more than a few generations to eliminate stereotypes that have been attached to girlhood and womanhood
There is a higher expectation on girls from a young age to be responsible and sensible. Even in like the school system as well, women are also normally what we would call the family's keeper, meaning they perform a lot of that invisible labour of making sure everybody's happy, that conflicts are resolved and everybody feels paid attention to. They keep the peace as mediators and they also don't call a lot of attention to themselves. And although many cultures are now turning away from that conventional and unequal treatment of girls and boys, particularly when it comes to domestic duties, it takes more than a few generations to eliminate stereotypes that have been attached to girlhood and womanhood|||社会对女孩从小就抱有更高的期望，要求她们懂事、听话。甚至在学校体制中也是如此，女性通常也是我们所谓的“家庭守护者”，这意味着她们承担了大量隐形劳动，确保每个人都开心、冲突得以解决、每个人都觉得自己受到了关注。她们作为调解者维持着和平，同时也不太引人注目。尽管许多文化现在正逐渐摒弃这种对女孩和男孩的传统且不平等的对待，特别是在家务分工方面，但要消除附加在女孩和女人身上的刻板印象，|||
for literally centuries for millennia. So there's always going to be some kind of residue that remains in our unconscious brains that it's causing us to implicitly, treat men and women differently. Some people try and deny that there is still unequal treatment of men and women, especially when it comes to the home. And as we see more progressive views towards domestic labor and female empowerment, we can also recognize that some women, you know, want to do those things. That is totally fine. But according to the UN, girls between the ages of five and 14 years old, so not really at a point where they can make like a conscious and like informed decision about how they want to live
for literally centuries for millennia. So there's always going to be some kind of residue that remains in our unconscious brains that it's causing us to implicitly, treat men and women differently. Some people try and deny that there is still unequal treatment of men and women, especially when it comes to the home. And as we see more progressive views towards domestic labor and female empowerment, we can also recognize that some women, you know, want to do those things. That is totally fine. But according to the UN, girls between the ages of five and 14 years old, so not really at a point where they can make like a conscious and like informed decision about how they want to live|||需要历经好几个世纪甚至几千年。因此，我们的潜意识中总会残留某种沉淀，导致我们在潜意识里区别对待男女。有些人试图否认男女之间依然存在不平等对待，尤其是在家庭方面。随着我们看到对家务劳动和女性赋权出现更多进步的观点，我们也能认识到有些女性，你知道的，就是想做那些事情。这完全没问题。但根据联合国的数据，5岁到14岁的女孩，也就是尚未真正具备对自己的生活方式做出有意识且知情的决定的年龄阶段，|||
their life, they spend 40% more time on domestic work than boys the same age. And on top of that, younger daughters spend more time on average than young sons doing chores that are consistent and very timely, right? So very intensive chores like keeping the house organized, cooking dinner every night, doing the cleaning, driving around siblings, providing almost free therapy to their parents, their siblings, their relatives. Whereas the jobs and the chores, that are commonly done by boys are like mowing the lawn, shoveling snow. Those are irregular. They're not as urgent. They're not as consistent. And the final statistic that really draws at home for me, I'm sure that we're all kind of convinced at this point, but this one really like made it very
在她们的生活中，她们花在做家务上的时间比同龄男孩多40%。不仅如此，与年幼的男孩相比，年幼的女儿平均要花更多的时间去做那些持续性强、时间紧迫的家务，对吧？也就是那些非常繁重的家务，比如保持家里整洁、每天晚上做饭、搞卫生、开车接送兄弟姐妹，几乎还要免费充当父母、兄弟姐妹和亲戚的心理咨询师。然而，男孩通常干的家务和活儿则是修剪草坪、铲雪。那些没有固定规律。不那么紧急。也没有那么连贯。最后一个真正戳中我的统计数据，我确信大家听到这里都已经深信不疑了，但这一个真的让我
apparent to me how like the eldest daughters, and just daughters in general take on so much of the emotional and physical burden. So in the UK, almost 70% of people who are what we would call sandwich caregivers, so that means that they are working and also looking after kids or elderly parents. 70% of those people are women. 70%. So in an article published by Atlantic this year, they refer to this very experience as daughtering. They have a term for it. It's called daughtering. It was coined by Alison Alford at Bailey University. And it's basically used to describe the family work that girls and women tend to take on. That can look like picking up prescriptions. planning retirement parties, setting money aside for the parents' future.
清楚地看到长女以及整个女儿群体承受了多少情感和身体上的负担。所以在英国，被称为“三明治照顾者”的人群中，近70%的人既要工作，还要照顾孩子或年迈的父母。这部分人里有70%是女性。70%。因此，《大西洋月刊》今年发表的一篇文章将这种经历称为“女儿化”（daughtering）。他们甚至有这样一个专有名词。这就叫“女儿化”。这个词是由贝勒大学的艾莉森·阿尔福德（Alison Alford）创造的。它基本上用来描述女孩和女性往往需要承担的家庭杂务。这可能表现为去取处方药、筹划退休派对、为父母的未来存钱。
And it can also involve more subtler actions like holding your tongue to avoid an argument or listening to your parents' worries. And this daughtering phenomenon happens for a few reasons. The major one being role modelling theory, where eldest daughters in particular often imitate how their mothers display and embody gender and also gender schema theory. So parents, society, often assigns different gender gender gender. tasks and expectations to boys and girls. You know, like boys are strong, girls are sensitive. Boys are like really physically active, girls are creative. Even if it's accidental, unconscious,
它还可能涉及更微妙的行为，比如为了避免争吵而选择隐忍，或者倾听父母的忧虑。这种“女儿化”现象的产生有几个原因。其中最主要的是角色建模理论，尤其是长女经常模仿母亲如何展现和体现性别特征，此外还有性别图式理论。因为父母和社会经常给男孩和女孩分配不同的、不同类别的性别任务和期望。你知道，比如男孩要坚强，女孩要敏感。男孩身体非常活跃，女孩富有创造力。即使这是无意的、潜移默化的、
cultural, it has an impact on how eldest daughters grow up to see themselves and how their personalities are often formed around their duty to others. So we can't really deny that if you are a daughter and you've been raised with brothers, for example, you're doing more labor here. Like, it's just common sense. Or in the case of like a family with only daughters, it may be that you begin to compensate for like your dad's chores. When we combine birth order, the fact that parents raise eldest children differently and then gender, this very societal, cultural, ingrained belief system almost about how women should behave. That is the space. That is the space that eldest daughter syndrome emerges.
源于文化的，它也会对长女长大后如何看待自己产生影响，并使她们的性格往往围绕着对他人的责任感塑造起来。所以我们真的无法否认，如果你是一个女儿，而且家里还有兄弟，比方说，你在这里确实付出了更多的心劳。这简直是常识。或者在只有女儿的家庭里，你可能会开始替你爸爸分担家务。当我们把出生顺序（父母对长子女的培养方式不同这一事实）与性别结合起来时，这种关于女性应该如何行为的社会化、文化化的、根深蒂固的信仰体系几乎就形成了。这就是空间。这就是长女综合征萌芽的空间。
Sometimes I'm going to acknowledge this now. That role can be really satisfying. I do. I love to talk and brag about my sisters because I feel like a little bit extra proud of them because I was a little bit extra involved in their lives. It's a good feeling, right? You can feel a lot closer to both your parents
有时候——我现在就要承认这一点——这种角色其实能带来很大的满足感。确实如此。我喜欢谈论我的姐妹并为她们感到骄傲，因为我对她们倾注了更多的心血，所以我对她们也多了一层格外的自豪感。这种感觉很好，对吧？你会觉得自己跟父母
and your siblings because you're kind of like you occupy the space in the middle. You have more of an independent drive. You're more ambitious. You have more leadership qualities. Those are all great things. but as we've spoken about, as numerous women have reported, there is also a burden that is very profound. One of the most common experiences is feeling like you never had a chance to fully, truly, live for yourself
和兄弟姐妹的关系都更亲密了，因为你有点像占据了中间的那个位置。你更有独立向上的动力。你更有野心。你具备更多领导才能。这些都是极好的特质。但正如我们所讨论过的，正如许多女性所反映的那样，这背后也伴随着一种极其沉重的负担。最普遍的经历之一，就是觉得自己从来没有机会真正地、彻底地为自己活一次，
because you always felt an added responsibility lingering in the background. Responsibility to look after your siblings, to care for your parents as they get older, to be a success story and set an example, to make money, to pay money, to pay the way and all of those things that results in a lot of both internal and external pressure that we're facing. Then, of course, sometimes we also see resentment beginning to bubble up as well, especially if your younger sibling got away with a lot more things than you did and were permitted more failures or screw-ups. They got to be a lot more carefree than you did. They kind of got to have a childhood. And I know that's really quite sad. Like, they got to be.
因为你总觉得有一份额外的责任在背景里挥之不去。照顾兄弟姐妹的责任，在父母年迈时照顾他们的责任，成为成功的故事并树立榜样的责任，赚钱、出钱、承担开销以及所有这些事情，导致我们面临着大量来自内部和外部的压力。当然，有时我们也会发现怨恨情绪开始滋生，尤其是当你的年幼手足比你少操心很多事情，并且被允许犯更多错误或搞砸更多事情时。他们比你过得无忧无虑得多。他们某种程度上算得上拥有过真正的童年。我知道这其实挺让人难过的。因为他们能够成为
that young, carefree kid without being forced to grow into like a caregiving or leadership position really early. Another element is kind of sometimes a competition that can begin to form between siblings, whereby the parents may constantly praise the eldest child or the firstborn, which makes the younger children, often the last born, feel as if they can never live up to the successes and achievements and standards of their elder sibling, or that their parents may even have a favourite. I have heard so many stories of this resentment really destroying family dynamics when we allow that bitterness to like simmer and boil over. Or additionally, if our parents have always, you know, put a lot more energy into the eldest child, that also creates a sense of like jealousy between the children. So it's like a hard dynamic to navigate from like every side of the equation.
那个年轻、无忧无虑的孩子，而不用被迫在很小的时候就承担起照顾别人或领导的角色。另一个因素有时是兄弟姐妹之间可能开始形成的竞争，父母可能会不断称赞最大的孩子或头胎，这会让年幼的孩子（通常是老幺）觉得他们永远无法达到大孩子那样的成功、成就和标准，或者觉得父母可能甚至偏心。我听过太多这样的故事：当我们任由这种苦涩情绪潜滋暗长并彻底爆发时，怨恨真的会摧毁家庭关系。此外，如果我们父母一直以来，你知道的，把更多精力放在大孩子身上，这也会在孩子们之间产生一种嫉妒感。所以从各个角度来看，这都是一种很难处理的关系。
But there are also so many people doing it successfully. And what I want to focus on next is how we as the eldest daughters can, start taking care of ourselves without continuing to buy into the expectations or need to keep other people happy. Because when we actually take ourselves off a pedestal, when we say I don't need to be perfect, I don't always need to be in control, I don't need to be this independent, the rest of the family and people around you also take you off a pedestal. So you're kind of doing everybody, like doing everybody a favour where you're evening out the playing field between yourself and your siblings, but also you're able to have like an actual adult relationship with your parents
但也有很多人成功地处理好了这种关系。我接下来想重点探讨的是，作为长女的我们如何才能开始照顾好自己，而不再盲目接受那些期望，也不用再去迎合别人、维持所有人的开心。因为当我们真正把自己从神坛上请下来，当我们说“我不需要完美，我不需要永远掌控一切，我不需要表现得这么独立”时，家里的其他人以及你身边的人也会把你从神坛上请下来。所以这其实是在帮所有人的忙，你拉平了你自己和兄弟姐妹之间的竞争环境，同时你也能和父母建立起一种
when you stop, you know, when you stop letting them make you into this golden child. Firstly, we need our families to recognize the unfair burden that may have been placed on us and redistribute that emotional, physical and mental labour more equally. Part of that is being vulnerable around what is expected of you and what you need taken off your plate. For example, if your mom keeps calling around about your younger siblings, even after you've left the house, try and redirect it and just say, hey, I think maybe this is something that you can talk to dad about, not me. Or you can talk to them about it, not me. You are not the third parent. Don't let yourself become the third parent here. Or a big one as the holidays come up,
真正平等的成年人关系——当你不再（你知道的）让他们把你塑造成这个“金童玉女”式的完美孩子时。首先，我们需要让家人认识到我们可能承受的不公负担，并更平均地重新分配那些情感、身体和心理上的劳务。这其中的一部分，就是坦诚地表达对你的期望以及你希望卸下哪些负担。例如，即使你已经搬出了家，如果你妈妈还是不断打电话来唠叨你年幼的弟弟妹妹的事，试着转移话题并直说：“嘿，我想这也许是你可以跟我爸谈谈的事，而不是我。”或者：“你可以跟他们谈谈，而不是我。”你不是第三个家长。不要让自己在这里变成第三个家长。或者在假期来临之际，这是一个很大的挑战：
you need to try and recognize when you are doing things to people please that you don't actually want to do. Stop volunteering for tasks that your brother or your dad could do or another person or just going along with everyone else's demands because it's easier for you to organize things than for other people to take responsibility. For example, if you have picked everyone up from the airport on all their separate flights and then you're having to rush home to prepare dinner and then you're also responsible for the family itinerary, be completely honest and say, hey, can someone else take something off my plate here? Or nominate. someone to do one of your tasks. Also, push back against the gender stereotypes. There is no reason
你需要学会识别，什么时候你做某些事只是为了取悦他人，而你内心其实并不想做。不要再主动揽下那些你弟弟、你爸爸或其他任何人本可以做的事，也不要再盲目顺从大家的要求，仅仅因为由你来统筹比让其他人承担责任更容易。例如，如果每个人都是坐不同的航班抵达，而你把所有人都从机场接了回来，接着你还得赶回家准备晚餐，同时你还要负责全家的行程规划，那就完全坦诚地说：“嘿，大家能不能帮我分担一点？”或者指派
that your brother can't do the dishes or that your dad can't like boil water for pasta. Like, they are not incompetent, they are adults and you are not their mother. You're their sister, their daughter, even if you were their mother. Still, not fair. Part of breaking down the indoctrinated gender roles that contribute to eldest daughter syndrome is starting at the part of the family unit. And also don't just feel like you're the only one who is going to take control here. Like that is that level of like hyper independence that we see so commonly where you just always say yes to things even when you have a lot going on because it's easier than saying no and having someone else do it wrong or having someone else screw it up. I know it feels so awkward
某个人去完成你的一项任务。此外，还要勇于打破性别刻板印象。没有任何理由
and uncomfortable at first because you have been playing this part for a long time. but I think that the discomfort will fade when you acknowledge that boundaries are sometimes at first going to feel hard because they don't just they just don't feel normal quite yet and it can also be difficult to start because you realize how much other people have come to rely on you but I think you'll also begin to notice how when you stop doing all of the additional physical and mental labour other people don't want to do it either because it's tiresome but it's It's less tiresome when it's actually evenly distributed. It's also important to start speaking your mind.
一开始你可能会觉得非常尴尬
Stop biting your tongue and trying to be the mediator or peacemaker all the time. If your parent makes a comment you don't like, say something. If they say something you don't agree with, tell them. If your sibling keeps asking you to intervene in their dispute with your mom or your dad, push back and just say, I don't really have an opinion. If someone is ranting at you and expecting you to just take it, interrupt them and say, hey, this is really putting me in a bad mood. I don't have space for this right now. That is especially the case with your parents, right? You are still their child. You are not their friend.
不要总是唯唯诺诺、试图充当调解人或和平缔造者。如果你父母说了一句你不喜欢的话，那就说出来。如果他们说的话你不敢苟同，那就告诉他们。如果你的兄弟姐妹一直要求你介入他们与你妈妈或爸爸的争执，那就顶回去，直接说：“我其实没什么看法。”如果有人向你抱怨并指望你全盘接受，打断他们并说：“嘿，这真的让我心情很糟糕。我现在没空听这些。”对父母尤其如此，对吧？你依然是他们的孩子。你不是他们的朋友。
You are not their parent. You are not their therapist. Don't let them parentify you here. It's also important to encourage balanced conversations that don't fear too severely into blaming your parents or your siblings. You really want to try and understand why, it might be this way. Like we've spoken about throughout this episode, all of the contributing factors and parenting, like parenting styles and behaviours that lead to
你不是他们的父母。你不是他们的心理咨询师。不要让他们把“家长的责任”强加给你。同样重要的是，要鼓励平衡的对话，不要过分偏向于责怪你的父母或兄弟姐妹。你真的需要试着去理解为什么事情会变成这样。正如我们在本集节目中所讨论的那样，所有导致
eldest daughter syndrome, they're often very subtle and difficult to recognise in the moment. And most of the time, our parents have learnt them from their parents, who learnt them from their parents. It's very generational. So be a bit forgiving
长女综合征的促成因素以及育儿方式和行为，往往都非常微妙，在当下很难被察觉。而且大多数时候，我们的父母也是从他们的父母那里学来的，而他们的父母又是从他们的父母那里学来的。这具有很强的代际传递性。所以在这里多一点包容与谅解，
here, because when we stoop to blaming them, rather than understanding, that's when riffs form in families because your parents will never hear you if you're just trying to criticize them, right? I know that you have a lot of anger, you have a lot of frustration, you don't want to silence yourself, but it's basically like putting yourself in this position where it's like, do I want to completely like damage this relationship and maybe not damage it, but like definitely heard it for a little bit? Or do I want to actually get something productive out of this? Like, do I actually want to see their behavior change rather than just see an
因为当我们沦为责怪而非理解时，家庭裂痕就会产生，因为如果你只是试图批评父母，他们是永远听不进去的，对吧？我知道你有很多愤怒，有很多挫折感，你不想让自己当个闷葫芦，但这就基本上等于把自己置于这样一种境地：“我是想彻底破坏这段关系——也许谈不上破坏，但肯定会让它受点伤？还是想从中得到真正有建设性的结果？我究竟是想看到他们的行为发生改变，还是只想看到他们情绪化的反应？”
emotional reaction from them? When we only blame, it's, you know, often our parents will never hear that the way that we want them to hear that. They'll never hear what we're actually saying, which is, I love you so much. I want our relationship to survive. So please, can we change this pattern of behavior that is putting me in this position? All they're going to hear is, you're a bad parent. You're a bad parent because it's this like cognitive strategy we all have to ignore criticism. So I think really sitting down and being with like, you know, saying to them, you know, this has been my experience and I want to let you know that I value our relationship, but this needs to change. I can't be this perfect child anymore. I can't always organize our lives. You cannot turn to me for emotional support all the time. Maybe
当我们只知道责怪时，往往父母是永远听不到我们真正的心声的。他们听不到我们实际在表达的意思，也就是：“我太爱你们了。我希望我们的关系能够长久。所以求求你们，我们能不能改变这种让我陷入这种困境的行为模式？”他们听到的只会是：“你们是不称职的父母。你们是不称职的父母。”因为这是我们所有人都会有的一种心理防御策略，用来忽视批评。所以我认为，真正静下心来跟他们沟通，对他们说：“这就是我的经历，我想让你们知道我很珍视我们的关系，但这种情况必须改变。我不能再当这个完美的孩子了。我不能总是包办我们的生活。你们不能总是找我寻求情感支持。”或许
you need a therapist. That's really important. My final tip is to start living for yourself. I think that that is the string that is tied together this whole episode. You do not need to be a child prodigy. You don't need to be the best all the time. You don't have to be the third parent. You don't have to be independent and self-reliant and do everything yourself. You don't always have to be the only one worrying about what it's going to go wrong. And the way to start doing this, the way to take that responsibility off your shoulders,
你需要一个心理咨询师。这真的很重要。我的最后一条建议是：开始为自己而活。我认为这是贯穿整集节目的核心主线。你不需要成为神童。你不需要时刻做到最好。你不需要当第三个家长。你不需要表现得独立自主、一切都亲力亲为。你不需要永远是唯一一个担心哪里会出问题的人。而开始这样做的第一步，把肩上的责任卸下来的第一步，
is to start asking for and accepting. help when you need it. Not just with your family, but with all the other people in your life. For example, if someone has offered to cook you dinner or get you dinner, instead of being like adamant that they shouldn't and being like, no, no thank you, no thank you. Embrace their generosity. They want to show you that they care. They want to do something kind for you because you deserve it. They know how much time and effort you put into others. You don't always have to be the one serving other people. Let them do this for you. Accept other people. Except other people. people's willingness to help you. I really struggled with this when I started dating my boyfriend
就是在你需要的时候开口寻求并接受帮助。不仅是对家人，对你生活中的所有人都是如此。例如，如果有人主动提出为你做晚饭或给你买晚饭，与其斩钉截铁地拒绝并说“不，不用了，谢谢，不用了谢谢”，不如欣然接受他们的慷慨。他们想向你表达他们的关心。他们想为你做件好事，因为你配得上。他们知道你为别人付出了多少时间和精力。你不需要永远是那个服务别人的人。让他们为你做这些吧。接受其他人。接受其他人
and he wanted to like pay for meals and like do things for me. I was like this is really, I'm so used to being this like hyper independent person who takes care of everyone else. Like what is going on? And then recently a friend of mine like stayed at my house and did all the dishes and like offered to like do my laundry. And it felt so odd to have someone do for me what I always felt like I needed to either do for myself or do for other people. But I want you to swallow that initial instinctual gut feeling to be in control, to be self-reliant, and realize that if someone didn't want to do something for you, they wouldn't offer. They want to show you that, they want to show you, I guess, the love that you always give to others. Similar to this, fight back against your chronic independence. If you are
愿意对你的帮助。当我刚开始和我男友约会时，我真的很不习惯这一点，
struggling at work or uni, it's okay to reach out for help, right? Or even support. It doesn't make you a failure for needing assistance. That's just your eldest daughter instincts stepping in, trying it's hardest to like make you always be the best and self-reliant. It's like okay to not be the best and everything. It's okay to ask for help the way that other people ask you for help, right? It actually shows really great strength. And I think finally, it's okay to do things for yourself and with yourself, even if it means disappointing others or saying no, whether that is your hobbies or taking a day to just like not interact with anyone or not going to that big family gathering because you're just really tired, not taking
在工作或学业上苦苦挣扎时，寻求帮助是没有问题的，对吧？甚至寻求支持也可以。这并不意味着你需要协助就是个失败者。那只是你内心深处长女的本能正在作祟，拼尽全力让你永远追求最好、凡事靠自己。其实没必要事事都做到最好，这没关系。像别人向你寻求帮助那样去寻求帮助，这完全可以，对吧？这实际上展现了非常强大的力量。最后我认为，为自己做事、独自做一些事是完全可以的，哪怕这意味着让别人失望或说“不”——无论是你的爱好，还是花一整天时间不和任何人互动，或者因为真的很累而选择不去那个盛大的家庭聚会，不去承担
on that extra responsibility. That is okay. That is totally okay. Just say I'm not going. You are not selfish. You do not need to feel shame for prioritizing yourself whilst everyone else is doing the exact same thing by relying on you. Like that is, they are getting the rest by putting all the burden on you. And I think that we really begin to recognize elder daughter syndrome when we just cannot take that burden anymore, when we are so mentally and emotionally exhausted. I think you'll find yourself feeling so free in those moments. You won't feel contained anymore. You'll feel less burnt out when you give up that control and with that responsibility. And I'm not saying that it's going to happen instantly because if you have been the eldest daughter for a long
那些额外的责任。这完全可以。这绝对没问题。直接说“我不去”。你一点也不自私。当你把优先权留给自己时，你不需要感到羞耻，而与此同时，其他人却在理所当然地依赖你，做着完全一样的事。这其实是他们在把所有的负担都压在你身上，从而他们自己去偷懒休息。我想，当我们再也无法承受那种负担、当我们在精神和情感上精疲力竭时，我们就会真正开始意识到长女综合征的存在。我想你会发现自己在那些时刻感到无比自由。你不会再感到被束缚。当你放弃那种控制欲和责任感时，你会觉得倦怠感减轻了。我并不是说这会瞬间发生，因为如果你当了很久的长女，
time you have been very much like this is your identity so it's going to be really hard to give up but maybe just start by giving up the things that you really don't have space for anymore you really don't have the space to just like always be on your own and to never trust others you don't have the space to always be organizing everything like this was one of the things i really noticed about myself as the eldest daughter was i just got sick of always being the friend who had to make plans with everybody. Like it was so tiring to be the one who everyone was always like, what are you doing this weekend? What are we doing this weekend? Can you book this? Like, you know, it was really tiring and I gave that up because I was like, I can't keep doing this. And people respond to the kind of, to your absence,
这种身份已经深深烙印在你的生活中，所以要放弃它会非常困难，但也许可以从放弃那些你实在无暇顾及的事情开始，你真的没有精力去永远特立独行、永远不信任别人。你没有精力去把每件事都大包大揽——这是我作为长女时真正注意到自己的事情之一，我只是厌倦了总是那个必须跟所有人约计划的朋友。做那个让每个人都来问“你这周末在干嘛？我们这周末干嘛？你能订一下这个吗？”的人，真的太累了，你知道的，这非常累，所以我放弃了，因为我想：“我不能再这样下去了。”而当你的缺席发生时，人们会有所反应，
until the kind of hole that you leave when you no longer do their mental labor for them. I think being the eldest daughter is such an emotional mind field at times. I really do get it. You also feel that sense of responsibility for your younger siblings. Like I said before, like you implicitly know that if anything was to happen to your parents, you would be the one in charge. Like, you're the one who's going to have to step up there. So even if you don't think about it often, there is always that implied sense of like, I need to make sure these kids are all right. Like, I need to protect them. And sometimes you just want to break. You want to break from all that responsibility. And, you know, you can't change how you were raised or your birth order,
直到你不再为他们承担心理劳务时留下的那种空白出现。我认为当长女有时真是一片情感雷区。我真的完全理解。你也会对年幼的兄弟姐妹产生那种责任感。就像我之前说的，你潜意识里知道，如果你的父母发生任何意外，你就会是那个掌舵的人。没错，你就是那个必须挺身而出的人。所以即使你平时不常去想它，那种隐含的责任感也始终存在：我得确保这些孩子都没事。我得保护他们。有时你只是想歇口气。你想从所有的责任中喘息一下。而且，你知道的，你无法改变自己的成长经历或出生顺序，
but you can begin to unlearn and heal the parts of you that feel the need to carry the burden of everyone else while still being perfect. Like you can't do everything all the time. So let yourself be a child again. Let yourself receive love rather than always having to give it out. Like you really, you deserve that. You deserve to heal. You deserve to be a happy eldest daughter.
但你可以开始反思并疗愈内心深处的那部分自己——那个总觉得自己必须背负所有人的负担同时还要保持完美的自己。你不可能随时随地把所有事情都做好。所以，让自己重新当一次孩子吧。让自己去接受爱，而不是总要向外付出。你真的、你配得上这一切。你配得上疗愈。你配得上做一个快乐的长女。
So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope that you learnt something from this episode. As an eldest child, I totally get it. I feel like this was, I was writing this episode just being like, yep, yep, that makes sense, that makes sense, tick that off the list, like, totally aligns with my experience. And I hope that maybe that was the case for you as well, where you felt heard, you felt seen by this research, by some of these personal experiences, and also thinking about ways to not just go into the holiday season, but into every season, in a healthier, healed
所以我真心希望你喜欢这一集。希望你从这一集里学到了东西。作为老大，我完全感同身受。我觉得我在写这一集的时候脑子里一直在想：“对，对，这太对了我完全赞同，把这一条从清单上勾掉，这完全符合我的经历。”我也希望你听完也有同感，从这些研究和一些个人经历中感受到自己被倾听、被看到，同时也开始思考如何不仅在假期里，而且在生活的每一个时期，都以一种更健康、更疗愈的
way, where you're not always taking on this role in the family. You're allowed to be more yourself and take on an identity that is more aligned with who you actually are. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you enjoyed it, if you think someone else needs to hear this, make sure you share a link with them and leave a five-star review. This is like our last solo episode of the year. I just realized that last solo episode. This year we're doing 12 days of guests in December. So for the rest of the month, for the rest of the year, we will just be. We will just be doing guest episodes. I've been working so hard on finding some amazing people to come on and every single conversation is just like so wise, so mind-blowing, so like just targeted and interesting and
方式生活，不再总是承担家庭里的这个角色。你完全可以更多地做你自己，拥有一个更符合你真实自我的身份。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。如果你喜欢它，如果你觉得身边的某个人也需要听听这番话，请务必把链接分享给他们，并留下一条五星好评。这是我们今年最后一期单人播客了。我刚刚意识到，这是最后一期单人播客。今年12月我们正在进行“12天嘉宾连麦”活动。所以在接下来的这个月里，在今年剩下的时间里，我们都将
fascinating. So I cannot wait for you guys to hear all of those episodes. Make sure you're following so that you get alerted when they start to come out. And if you have an episode suggestion, please feel free to DM me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. This is where this episode came from like I talked about it very briefly in the overachieving episode and the amount of you that said I want to hear about the eldest daughter was insane. So thanks for your suggestion. I really hope that you enjoyed this episode and we will be back at the end of this week with another one. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building
推出嘉宾访谈期数。我一直在非常努力地寻找一些非常棒的嘉宾来做客，每一场对话都充满了大智慧、颠覆认知，既有针对性又极其有趣、
resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
引人入胜。所以我迫不及待地想让大家听到所有这些精彩内容。请确保点击关注，这样它们一上线你就能收到提醒。如果你有什么节目建议，请随时在Instagram上私信我 @That Psychology Podcast。本期节目就是这么来的，正如我之前简单聊过的，在讲“过度成就者”那一期时，大家强烈要求听听关于长女的话题，人数多得惊人。所以感谢你们的建议。我真的希望你喜欢这一集，我们会在本周末带着新节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能锻炼以及
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，可在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的对象竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我要做他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说：相信你的闺蜜。收听《相信闺蜜，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe）。可在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。
84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere,
从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何在朋友、喜剧同行和最喜爱作家的陪伴下挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代那样。
but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。收听《回看当年》（Look Back at It），可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的必修课》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kier Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法展开的坦诚对话，